We are almost ready to develop a
fast algorithm for finding the 2-Break
Distance.
The only thing left for us to accomplish
it is to prove the 2-Break Distance
theorem.
Let's consider an arbitrary transformation
of genome P into genome Q.
We don't know what 2-breaks accomplish
this transformation.
But what we know is that during
this transformation, the breakpoint graph
of P and Q
changes into the breakpoint graph of Q
with itself.
Which means that the cycle number of P and
Q is changing into the
cycle number of Q with itself which in
turn is simply the number of blocks in Q.
Therefore,
whatever transformation of P and Q
accomplishes it,
the number of red-blue cycles increases by
the number of blocks
in the genomes P and Q minus the number of
cycles between P and Q.
And therefore, the next question I will
ask,
how much each 2-break can contribute to
this increase
in the number of cycles?
Let's look into this.
Well, there are different scenarios on
which two red
edges from the breakpoint graph to break
effect.
Every 2-break removes two red edges.
Consider for instance the case
when these two red edges belong to the
same cycle in the break point graph.
In this case shown on this slide two red
edges are removed,
substituted by another two red edges, but
the cycle number doesn't change.
Here's another case where the same two red
edges are
removed from a single cycle in the break
point graph.
But the cycle number this time increases
by one.
And now lets consider the case when two
removed red
edges belong to two different cycles.
You can see that in this case doesn't
matter
which two red edges replace these removed
red edges.
The cycle number doesn't change.
Actually, the cycle number decreases by
one in this case.
And therefore, each 2-break increases
the number of cycles by at most one.
We almost proved this theorem.
But actually, we haven't proved it yet.
My previous slide was simply an invitation
for you to look at the picture.
Let's give a little bit more formal proof.
So a 2-break adds two new red edges,
and thus creates at most two new cycles in
the breakpoint graph.
On the other hand, it removes two red
edges, and thus destroys at least one old
cycle in the breakpoint graph.
And therefore, the change in the number of
cycle is at most 2 minus 1
which is at most 1, and on the
other hand, if you
watched carefully my proof, then you noticed,
there is always a 2-break increasing the
number of cycles by 1, and here it is,
the central case here present.
In example of such increase.
And now is the 2-break distance theorem.
We saw that each 2-break increases the
number of cycles by at most 1.
On the other hand, there exists a
2-break
increasing the number of cycles by exactly 1.
On the other hand it is so that every
sorting by 2-break must increase the
number of cycles by
the number of blocks between P and Q,
minus the number of
cycles between P and Q, and therefore
the 2-break distance between
genomes P and Q is simply the number of blocks
between P and Q
minus the number of cycles within P and Q.
And armed with the theorem, we actually
can compute
the 2-break distance between
circularized human and mouse chromosomes.
We know that human and mouse genomes can
be decomposed into 280 synteny blocks.
Each of these blocks will be larger than
half a million nucleotides in length.
The breakpoint graph on this block if we
look at this actually contains 35 cycles.
And therefore the 2-break distance
between human and mouse equals to 245.
Remember this number because it will be
important in the next section.
Now there are numerous 245 step scenarios,
and we do
not claim that we know which one of them
is correct.
Moreover, the true scenario may have more
than 245 steps.
Important thing for us is to remember that
there are at least 245 steps
to proceed to our next section,
where we will analyse the random breakage
model.